in what capacity did you start at the
aclu foundation in 2005. i was the
aclu's first in-house lawyer my title
was senior corporate council how much
has
ms heard
paid directly to the aclu
um i that would be 350 000 paid directly
when we initially um
had contact with amber heard in 2016
she indicated her desire to pay 3.5
million dollars to the aclu and
that was and and these were amounts that
were in relation to
that um
her having expressed that that's what
she wanted to pay to the aclu
so it's fair to say that she has not
donated 3.5 million dollars as of today
to the aclu
that's true when you say that mr depp
our client donated 100 000 to be
credited toward amber heard
did the aclu in fact credit that 100 000
toward the 3.5 million dollars
ms heard promised to donate to the aclu
we do credit
did miss heard direct you to credit it
to the to her account as it were we
asked ms heard if we should credit it
and she said that we should mr daugherty
have you ever seen exhibit 46 which is
aclu
debates number 12
87
yes what is it
this is a um
statement by robin shulman saying that
um
that
the
article that they're referring to
basically um
you know
recasts everything that is said but but
ties it to johnny depp
so ms shulman is agreeing with mrs
white's characterization
that
the usa
took mr ms heard to be referring to
her allegations of physical violence by
johnny depp correct
yes
and she says it's kind of amazing that
they just grabbed the entire op-ed and
rewrote it using johnny's name why was
it amazing i don't know why she found it
amazing
because that was consistent with your
understanding she was referring at least
in part to johnny depp correct
now based on my review of prior drafts
of the op-ed i knew that they were that
that she was referring to johnny depp in
her marriage and directing your
attention to the first page in this
exhibit
do you see
the email from mr romero to mr maresco
uh
subject a quick question
mr romero asked did elon's other gifts
come from vanguard
what does that refer
my personal knowledge is that anthony
was just asking whether um
other
gifts from elon musk had been issued
from recommendations he made to vanguard
regarding his
donor advice funded vanguard and mr
maresco then responds
one of them yes his five million dollar
gift in february 2017
was from vanguard do you see that
i see it
and if you look at the next page
vanguard was the same entity
that made the
soft credit contribution
in amber heard's name to the tune of 500
000 correct
correct
and he says in any case my understanding
was that the 500 000
from vanguard
was recommended by e m do you see that
yes
and e m stands for elon musk correct
correct
and also in that email above that
uh mr maresco uh
states that
mr musk's 1 million dollar gift in may
2018
was from fidelity do you see that
yes he must have either that means
a separate donor advice fund he has a
fidelity or
from
fidelity um
you know
in direct investment accounts he has a
fidelity i'm assuming the former but i
don't know
and if you look at the next page in uh
the salesforce chart
the second payment credited to
ms heard
for 350 000
as of
december 11 2018
came from
that same fidelity correct i don't know
the answer to that question i know that
um it came
from
a fidelity
donor advised fund the 350 000 but i
don't know if it is
elon musk's donor advice funded at
fidelity
but it could be
it could be
okay let's look uh at the second page of
the exhibit
an email from tyler richard to jessica
weitz
who is tyler richard
it's richard tyler and he uh and
no it's tyler richard that's right tyler
richard and he is a senior person in our
communications department
uh and mr richard says amber heard is an
aclu ambassador for women's rights since
2018
she has she also pledged her full
settlement to charity do you see that i
do
um
and miss white's response yeah i think
that's safer
i had nightmares about this last night
i'm very upset do you think this is okay
why was ms white so upset
about the characterization
of miss hurts charitable donations or
lack thereof
my understanding is that as a
communications department professional
um jessica was um concerned about these
um
news articles that were appearing and
what impact they would have on um you
know the the how the aclu and its work
with amber has seen
she was concerned that the aclu was not
telling the truth
about
amber's paying the 3.5 million correct
i don't see it that way i see it as her
doing everything she can in order to
produce a correct statement to the press
and can you generally just tell us a
little bit about what you do uh for mr
depp as his security guard
um i will escort johnny to everyday uh
public
places can you generally describe for us
what you remember about the the marks
you saw on mr depp
yes uh
as i was saying
in the prison service you're taught to
uh
pick up log in your mind mental mental
logging in your mind
marks bruises bully patterns stuff
what i noticed right away was most of
these marks and most of these things
through my training
is happening in the left-hand side of
his face
and it would be scratches on his neck
maybe a a fat lip in the corner
maybe a bruising on on the eye socket
um
dull impacts you know except for
obviously the scratches maybe on his
billy's left ear sometimes it'd be two
two marks two lines two charms
one
yeah you know
yeah
it was getting it was getting more
regular i might as i say not every week
but it was definitely happening yeah
can we see um
plaintiff's exhibit 162 please
and mr connolly uh are you able to see
the picture on i assume you can see it
on your screen
yeah just thank you please
yeah hi yeah
and do you uh
yeah i know that picture i took that
picture you took pictures
yeah i took the picture
can you just quickly tell us uh what
what this picture is
this picture is a
mess head and johnny's
honeymoon
all right and and mr connolly i
apologize for cutting you off but could
you just continue to describe for us uh
what we're looking at in this picture
yeah as i said the guy in the bow tie
he's the guest relations manager he was
detailed to
you know
fixes up anything we needed
you know to excursions and
transports and stuff
then it's misheard the guy that's the
chef who looked after this he was he
cooked for his great chef by the way uh
yeah he looked after us and that's
johnny and i also notice if you look at
that picture
like i said on the left hand side under
his eye there's a swelling
and you see a swelling just on the left
hand side of his nose and under his left
eye
and what do you interpret that swelling
to be do what do i what
he's walked into a door
or a door's walked into him
okay
you